invité du 12/13 antoine gaudino
ex-inspecteur pardon et de la brigade
financière du srpj de marseille
merci d'être d'être avec nous je ne suis
pas un tour du côté de la part dont
excusez moi vous avez participé
indirectement à cette enquête puisque d
une erreur de personnes que se
passe-t-il
nous avons un problème nous avons un
problème peut-on m'expliquer en régie ce
qu'est ce problème vous nous parler nous
avons enfin nous revenons nous revenons
dans un instant à vous excuser moi la
france conforme aux critères de
maastricht à l'issue du conseil des
ministres
dominique strauss kahn l'a annoncé il a
affirmé qu'il avait tenu sa parole
lorsque j'ai annoncé au mois de juillet
à la suite de l'audit qu'il y aurait des
milliards de francs d'économies à 7
assez petit 600 maisons seront ils
aujourd'hui on voit qu'ils sont là le
déficit budgétaire de 97 sera après le
vol du collectif inférieur à celui que
la loi de finances initiale avait prévu
mais il fallait aussi éviter que les
dépenses des rapports l'audit faisait
apparaître que les dépenses avaient
dérapé
elles ont été ramenées au niveau qui
était prévu initialement c'est la
première fois depuis quatre ans que le
budget c'est le réalise avec des
dépenses exactement au niveau de ce qui
a été voté par les députés lorsqu'ils
ont voté le budget je crois que ça c'est
un grand résultat en soi
deuxième grand résultat en soi c'est que
déficit budgétaire de 97 sera finalement
inférieur à celui que l'ancienne
majorité avait voté à
l'automne dernier alors que vous vous
souvenez a des arguments de la
dissolution était sans doute plus tard
était explosif est impossible à
maîtriser
nous revenons à cette escroquerie
parisienne cette vaste escroquerie
antoine gaudino le vrai me rejoint je
rappelle que vous êtes un ex inspecteur
de la brigade financière du srpj de
marseille
vous êtes indirectement liées à cette
enquête puisque des banques vous on vous
ont consulté 67 personnes sont en garde
à vue
la pj parisienne a mis des moyens
considérables dans cette affaire c'est
c'est une grande première dans ce
domaine assurément si l'on s'en tient
aux préjudices qui est annoncée près
d'un milliard de francs
c'est probablement une des plus grosses
escroqueries de ces derniers temps mais
il faut dire que la répartition par
personne ramène quand même des
dividendes qui sont limitées en france
il ya beaucoup plus d'escroquerie par
individualités jeudi avec des personnes
peuvent commettre à elles seules des
escroqueries de 500 millions de francs
sans que on s'en inquiète pour autant
mais quand même ce qui est tout à fait
surprenant dans cette dans cette affaire
c'est que comment peut-on en arriver là
que s'est il passé pour que codante
banques se se fassent avoir par cette
escroquerie
parfaitement organisée et qui
fonctionnait depuis plusieurs mois elle
est très organisée à l'europe
elle repose sur un système qui consiste
à observer ce qui se passe et détecter
les défaillances les failles alors en
matière bancaire le l'absence de
communication fait que les banques sont
vulnérables
il suffit je prends un exemple il suffit
pour un client d'aller dans une banque
de demander un réhaussement de sa ligne
de crédit et de répéter l'opération cinq
fois de suite au moment de l'échéance y
dépose son bilan il se fait liquider les
banques n'ont vu que du feu et se font
voir parce qu'elle communique pas d'un
autre âge
un deuxième exemple qui va nous éclairer
un client va aller voir une banque avec
une liste de factures de créances qui va
demander à mobiliser
et pour avoir du crédit au moment où la
banque va à demander son remboursement
il va s'apercevoir que les quinze les
vins les 30 entreprises qui ont sur
lesquels du papier a été tirée se
mettent tous en dépôt de bilan et je
dire disparaissent dans cette affaire
les banques ont eu du mal à travailler
main dans la main
absolument et je ne peux leur donner
qu'une qu'un conseil c'est qu'en
fonction de cela et je l'avais déjà
annoncé il ya plusieurs mois il ya qu
une attitude ses communiqués et prévenir
finalement le braquage paraît beaucoup
plus risqués est moins facile que la
délinquance financière qui elle se
développe à un rythme spécialistes
passent aujourd'hui c'est une mutation
de la délinquance du braquage d'antan
qui a évolué vers le monde des
entreprises mais la crise a réduit les
possibilités et aujourd'hui on s'attaque
aux établissements de crédit
demain la bourse s'est déjà fait de rire
antoine gaudino je vous remercie pour
votre témoignage